[Applause]
true
[Music]
viewer discretion is advised bad girls
[Music]
bad girls bad girls what you gonna do
what you gonna do when they come for you
bad girls bad girls what you gonna do
what you gonna do when they go
[Music]
feminist cops is filmed on location with
the brave strong women of law
enforcement all suspects are innocent
until proven guilty in a court of law
man down amanda we have a civilian in
critical condition we need medic staff
okay i'm here now i'm gonna save you
you're gonna be fine
um
ugh
[Music]
i didn't make it
bad girls bad girls what you gonna do
what you gonna do when they go for you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
that's an enraged sip
we're going through run through this
morning uh while you were still
nestled safely in your bed um
i was very angry i was told to save it
yes for the program yeah
apparently my anger amuses you so uh
it's aimed at europe just to be clear
it's no one here unless you're in europe
then it is aimed at you
and i don't care if you live or die i
just want to be clear about that
i hate europe i hate everything about
europe now just to be clear that
includes
everyone in europe red and yellow black
and white you're all [ __ ] in my
sight i don't care so it's not a racism
thing it's a continental thing
and we're going to be talking about the
world economic forum today we're going
to be talking about the arrogance of
europe that they spout during peace
years and then all of a sudden come to
the table to beg for the scraps from the
united states of america and then we're
also going to talk about the united
states of america and joe biden playing
ball former vice president biden who
just canceled some
oil and natural gas leases here in the
united states while we have an
electrical grid that won't be able to
support your electric cars so
my question to look we've asked this
before are you aware that the great
reset is not a conspiracy do you know
that
do you know that klaus schwab wrote a
book
with that if i'm not mistaken in the
title it's just a coincidence yeah
[Music]
so what is it but let me ask you this
what does it mean to you like a book
report what is a great set reset mean to
you i'll tell you what it does mean it
means your life's gonna suck
all right
so this is just you know they said they
are getting increasingly bold to say the
quiet part out loud at the world
economic forum it's like they don't even
know that there are cameras on at this
thing they just don't care no crying out
loud
just like yesterday sweden sweden sweden
wants to join nato no
no how about that you know i'm i grew up
in canada let me just start let me just
get it off my chest okay before anything
else by the way in case i get canceled
today on here on youtube it's a live
show monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern you can tune in on rumble monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern you can
watch it on mug club we're gonna play
another
game today hate symbol or not no way we
could play that on youtube another 45
minutes but here's the thing sweden
wanting to join nato is so emblematic of
what i experienced when i was raised in
canada canadians would say well we're
better than the united states we have uh
we have uh socialized health care no you
don't you don't have free health care
you have american subsidized health care
just like sweden sweden oh we made
internet to human rights i know that's
technically germany but they make a
bunch of stuff you know human rights
they're like gummy fish and
shoot yeah there you go
a ship gg13 swedish fish i know it's in
the name chefs chefs but they sit there
and talk about all these rights that you
don't give in america and then we've
been paying the tab nato four percent of
our gdp the agreement is two percent
most nations don't even pay that four
percent of our gdp on nato military
spending so we nothing they brag about
being neutral they brag about all these
rights that they give people and now
once they're at that point where oh oh
hold on a second shit's about to get
real it's can we join nato no no no no
no no no how about first off you pay
your back tab which of course you can't
do because you spent it on a bunch of
other frivolities
and you know what if you don't enjoy
being enslaved by whoever wants to do it
how about you start by making your navy
more than a guy in a tugboat with a
shotgun then we'll talk about you being
able to [ __ ] about free human rights
that you give out in your country and
then we set the world economic forum and
these people are going to tell us how we
need to live
how we need to help
you [ __ ] about the united states oh
look in canada america america is an
evil empire oh really i noticed that
you're coming to the evil empire with
your hand out right now isn't that right
ukraine we're gonna need sanctions to be
aggressive and
okay
make them aggressive ukraine oh oh
that's right you don't have the ability
to
neither does anyone in europe
anyway yes
oh oh oh nation building just shut up
just shut up and go
die i mean as
a concept europe that's also why i
disagree with the identitarian rights
the right winger like we need uh western
european well guess what western europe
screwed it up
that's why we left it yes
i don't want the united states to be
like western europe for crying out loud
why yeah
what we need we need more monkey pox
running around you know what hey let's
just contain monkey pox ship everyone
with monkey pox to europe and then let
it run its course
do your thing i think that's fair they
started it oh america you're so well oh
yeah yeah yeah okay who's going to come
up with the vaccines
you just human centipede email i think
that's the way yeah that's how you get
rid of it no that's how you get rid of
europe all right exactly
that's what i'm trying to do i'm sorry
i'm sorry for just i just had to get it
out of my system a little bit because i
just i'm we're going to go through the
top five moments so if you do not have
the stomach to watch the world economic
form and i did not i would rather watch
amber heard fake cry on the stand
plenty of that so we have the top five
moments it'll be everything that you
really need to know all references
available at literal credit.com and then
of course the new energy policy which is
uh designed to appease those at the
world economic forum from our former
vice president
joseph biden
famous father of crack gigolos gerald a
is here how are you sir i am doing well
you're a little fiery this morning i
just hate europe so much and i know it's
wrong to hate i just want to know why
sweden didn't join earlier hey you're
you're related to the party you
understand theology better than i do
does the bible forbid against hating a
continent
i don't believe it says anything about
continence there we go what about like
an organization like like a union like
the european union
i still think that's fair so i'm not
sinning i'm not that i know of good
because then otherwise i'd have to have
whoopi goldberg explain communion to me
you vicar of christ
[Laughter]
still fiery huh didn't get another young
pope there's a new pope fan club shirt
yes
yeah she has a new show coming out
called the stupid pope are you serious
no
see i believed it
it's 20 22 yeah it's not easy today you
never know and yeah you love him the
quickest with
in the west you can follow him on
twitter at landau dave he's going to be
uh may 29th in gaylord michigan fuel
festival
um and uh uh gaylord michigan just
actually had a tornado touchdown and
destroy a big part of the city so if i'm
not mistaken all the proceeds are going
to rebuild the town correct yeah
everybody affected by the tornado will
get the proceeds from the show one 100
of them the guy who owns conservative
dude and he has been feeding the town
please buy tickets come on to the show
it's may 29th so that's that's the
sunday this sunday there you go this
sunday may 29th go out support it sunday
sunday sunday and uh also um
don't pull a bono on us and say that the
proceeds are going and then it actually
goes to you but it's just it's all me
okay i'm gonna be like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
male hookers is that the edge it's dave
sunglasses watch me watch me put my
unwanted [ __ ] on your iphone yeah
i'm here to kill your town
i bet you that guy has monkey pox all
right the razor lander yes and i ride up
on a razor scooter
slash landau
[Laughter]
self-given nicknames oh my gosh i just
can't stand it that's one thing in
brazilian jiu jitsu they don't let you
do it they don't let you do sale you'll
come in you're like i want to be no the
warrior crusher like how about big ears
you're now called big ears
well the cedric the entertainer when
he's like yo man call me delicious he's
like i'm a grown-ass man i'm not calling
you
that's how i feel all right so before we
get to that uh a feel-good story here uh
some california uh jewelry thieves
they've been out the hallway uh hard way
the hard way that uh koreans don't mess
around in scent in huntington beach it's
not san francisco so this is i believe
korean brother and sister and if not i'm
just going to pretend like they're
korean because they need some wins
and uh there's another female employee
kicked the crap out of these would-be
smash and grabbers
you're looking at security footage from
princess bride diamonds in huntington
beach sunday may 22nd at noon
one customer look at that
little dude has fast hands
she's kicking the guy on the ground i
love it
bam figures enter the diamond shop bam
oh need him begin to smash and grab
their way to some expensive rocks and
jewelry but the response from staffers
including a brother and sister boom
kicking it on the ground watch this bam
bam bam get them again
just as forceful the footage showing
them punching and kicking how
embarrassing for you guys yeah
[Laughter]
and hits one of the intruders over the
head you can see hammers fists and feet
flying that guy doesn't care
that could have ended really badly for
that woman with that hammer swinging she
doesn't care look women generally
speaking get their butts kicked by men
but i got to i have to appreciate the
boldness amid a growing body she just
played decks hard problem with that is
that video needs more nine millimeter
yes
and except 12 gauge
just want to be clear i don't know if
they've been charged yet because it's
california would have no i would prefer
that the woman
that's what i would prefer why so that
she doesn't have to risk getting hurt
you're just saying you'd prefer a loss
of life yes yes i would i would prefer a
loss of life if it means that that woman
doesn't hit the head with a hammer she
shouldn't have to take that risk right
you went in and by the way can we just
put like some if it doesn't have to be
bulletproof hammer proof glass and
jewelry stores do not think
but that video i would like to see that
woman uh remain in a completely safe
physical space and blow him away
i i think that's fair they're very smart
so i'm sure they have tape of the guy
four days ago casing it right it's like
what kind of glass is this yes
you mean the diamond no no just
physically this glass yeah it's fast is
it like like glass glass yeah like could
it be penetrated with i don't know a
hammer
[Laughter]
i don't know what what kind of hammer
american steel like what do you think
depends
what about a pickaxe yeah i handle that
what about these a tactical pen
shut up are those ring doorbells or no
those are real security cameras all
right okay i'll be back all right thanks
like what you're doing here yeah well
the the korean shopkeepers are smart so
they were probably expecting that
mission like oh no can't believe it my
worst nightmare you show bam bam
oh they're pulling up i'll hide in the
back yes yeah they subbed out all their
workers just people from taekwondo while
they were in there someone is outside
laying down banana peels yeah yeah
their car skids off the road i'm i'm
sorry we are so far removed from
remember when people would say no the
wars are fought over uh they try to use
the term geopolitics to soften it hey
are you starting to see now war is
always about resources
and by the way human beings fight over
resources this is why the lockdowns and
removing people's livelihoods was a
bigger deal than just oh yo we're all in
this together no we're not you first
john kerry in your private jet mr
climate czar i think we're so far
removed that you have some people who
would see those thieves get blown away
by an innocent woman and be horrified i
wouldn't i wouldn't even miss dinner not
at all they swung a hammer at your head
and tried to kill you you get to defend
your life yes done i don't trust anybody
with the name czar in the title
yes that was a bad move maybe a drug
czar and a climate sar does that make
sense well he probably is yeah it's true
he needs to be a clown czar
well speaking of clowns are whoopi
goldberg
[Laughter]
now because i don't know if you know
this nancy pelosi she was she was denied
communion by the archbishop there in uh
san francisco there you go
and people are saying oh that's not your
job
that's kind of his main job
it's definitely they do get to decide
who yeah that's communion actually yeah
yeah
i'm and by the way i'm not catholic but
i have a lot of appreciation for i got
in trouble because i took communion
catholic i went to a public school a
catholic school in canada you did math
public catholic school and i was taking
communion in a non-denominational
christian church so i didn't realize and
so i took communion of the catholic
church
and i learned very quickly that it's a
big deal and they get to choose who's a
member of the church and so listen
they have freedom of religion and by the
way they have a hierarchy as to who
determines
which attendees are allowed communion
this didn't sit well with vicar of
christ whoopi goldberg who decided to uh
say stuff
welcome to the view y'all
the abortion rights battle is starting
to blur the lines between church and
state the archbishop
of san francisco
is calling for speaker nancy pelosi to
be denied receiving communion because of
her pro-choice stance he's one of the
priests who also called for president
finally denied sacrament this is not
your job dude yes it is not you can't
wait
watch her go to her notes
you know what is the saying it's kind of
amazing
uh
but big applause on that you know
what is the point of communion right
it's for uh sinners oh you needed a
flashcard for the word sinners it's the
reward of saints but the bread of
sinners how dare you
what oh gosh you had notes and it was
still asinine and you read it wrong it
is not the reward of sinners but the
bread of saints and that's still wrong
yeah that's actually not accurate i was
going to say i went through uh
baptism and then the other two yeah the
other things i did those the one you do
in eighth grade and the second greatest
thing confirmation that's it thank you
so she actually said oh you know no i
was a made guy that's not your job dude
and what's coming what is communion dude
hey child ever what's communion it's for
it's one lot of little weight wafers you
know it is for
hold up i bring my own cheese hold on
i like crackers hold up
sinners
[Laughter]
no
no why have you lost faith in your
institutions wasn't he calling her a
sinner basically yeah he's like
say you're a murderer you can eat
crackers
an unrepentant sinner this is what the
problem is and the lord said let those
who murder babies have triscuits
yes
biscuits and goods wheat thins for all
sinners and terrible wine the worst
shared with everyone give it to your
kids
and the [ __ ] who looks like predator
engaged in consuming ritz crackers
with much cheese yay verily
so
let me read you from u.s catholic here
it says those who obsidly persist in
manifest graves in are not to be
admitted holy
communion well that seems pretty
straightforward yeah right and by the
way the bible does say catholics take
this very seriously if you take
communion unworthily basically like you
are in sin and you think it's not sin
even though you know that the bible says
it is sin killing babies you are not
allowed to do that and you do it to your
own destruction right basically you're
thumbing your nose at god so thank
goodness that the archbishop stepped in
and saved nancy pelosi that who are you
to tell me i can't
hey hey wait wait a minute okay who are
you to tell me i can't throw my nose
well you can't it it's itchy but gotcha
it's itchy baby
well it's you know as us italians and
irish tend to be usually catholics yeah
they're a very easy group for her to go
after i'd like to see any other religion
and her to make a stance against it yeah
yeah yeah yeah let's see her go after
you know one of the imams who were you
to throw homos off a rooftops child yeah
she's not gonna say that yeah actually
she goes
rooftop rooftop
let me get the quote wrong what i
understand is that in saudi arabia if i
have this right hold up
women hey
hey hey okay hold up women can't even
[ __ ] all day hey
that was right at the top yeah this is
no prompter drive
oh i'm sorry whoopi were you still
talking
she was still thinking i'm over here
beating myself they care about their
health all the women had masks
i mean they and by the way they're way
here in america people get bothered
having to wear a mask they go further
than the n95 they cover the whole body
that's health
ain't no monkey pox can't touch their
lesions because can't touch their body
it's crazy
kovid can't get through a burqa okay
she wanted to stick up for nancy pelosi
yes right by the way can we start a
petition for whoopi goldberg to be uh
cloaked in a burqa for the rest of all
time yeah let's do that i don't know
whitehouse.gov change.org
well how does nancy pelosi walk into a
church and not just burn you see wings
come out
like 30 days of night when josh says
goodbye it's like it's like constantine
yeah you just see like claws and this
ash forming
the next time she goes in for a blowout
just like yeah hold on let me get it
just uv light surprise [ __ ]
it burns it's a day walker
oh this is an angry day
uh hit the like button if you're okay
with it when we're a little bit angry
yeah speaking of places i don't like san
francisco can we make them a part of
europe
the mayor london breed uh though i
appreciate part of this and then don't
appreciate the other part uh she uh
announced that uh
unless the pride activists for the gay
pride parade
reversed their ban on uniform police
because they they're banning uniformed
police at the private good idea that she
wouldn't be marching with them which
sounds kind of okay
and then
one month until the country's most
storied pride parade returns from a
two-year pandemic pause
but today entire city agencies say
they're dropping out that's because
pride organizers say they're banning any
officer from walking in the parade in
uniform and from san francisco mayor
london who don't like uniforms who says
she will stand in solidarity with
officers and skipped the parade writing
quote we can't say we want more black
officers or we want more lgbtq officers
about good officers and then treat those
officers with disrespect when they
actually step up and serve we're just
disappointed because we love the mayor
she's part of san francisco pride and
we hate that she made that decision
what
[Laughter]
yeah it's like we can't say we want more
black officers in lgbtq uh we didn't
we just i don't know does anyone hear
anyone ever say like hey hey hold on we
need more uh we need more cops shut up
black gay cops
uh that seems specific oddly enough
can't they design the own their own
uniforms at least for the day make them
fun yeah make them sequin what if they
go on assless chaps will that work does
that fit in can we all wear a uniform of
your choosing yes
well actually would help once of doing
perps you know sequins like
all right put my hand on it just don't
let it rub off on me
see a gun and a paddle
furry handcuffs and regular handcuffs
yes you choose
are they just give me the plush ones
oh [ __ ] got a paddle all right all
right i'll go i'll go i'll go all right
uh well that's very cool though i will
save the mayor she's very clearly
serious about law and order
yeah i don't know uh what the big deal
is it's not like anyone would even
notice an officer anyway right well
actually um let's pull up a picture from
the 2019 parade i believe we have
fabulous yeah see i have no idea who the
cop is where's waldo no
no idea
just like waldo hanging out you know
hiding in the candy cane forest yeah you
can't tell i can't tell
no puns intent like that's just a group
of gay men yeah i know i just i it's
just everything bleeds together yeah
can't tell so
let's get by the way best thing you can
do if you're watching here on youtube
right now is share sharing is uh caring
i guess because that's the new algorithm
on youtube they change the like stuff
liking helps comments always help the
best comment will be pinned to the top
and you win a lock of gerald's back here
but sharing does help ooh not head hair
back here and some people ask us can i
share by text yeah you can share however
you want youtube just says oh look at
shares share no let's make sure that the
notifications really don't work oh and
by the way can you comment below we had
a lot of comments last week with people
saying hey
uh notifications finally worked today
really and then of course the viewership
went up dramatically so look i know like
our viewership is being throttled here
on youtube but it
i don't know i don't know how long we'll
be here nothing would thrill me more
greatly than for all of you to head over
to rumble and mug club but you know i
can't force you i'm not a i'm not a
world economic forum communist so
[Laughter]
let's get to the world economic forum
this is where the world's elite gather
to pee on redwoods i'm sorry
davos switzerland
to laugh at all the plebes
and uh let's get to the top five moments
here from the world economic uh form
because it's pretty tough to sort of
you know parse through it i get that and
it's also a pride swallowing siege that
i will never fully tell you about when i
have to watch this crap
so moment number five
all right do we have a no here we go
yeah okay that was delayed ding it's
like you had to look at your notes like
whoopi goldberg all right number five
number five dang hold on
hold on wait wait hold up hit the ding
chill
bam just and i hate it's a lazy argument
say someone's stupid
she's a stupid person she really is well
yeah the holocaust wasn't i mean there's
yeah lots of other stuff but i
understand what she's saying in the
sense she was trying to say it wasn't
necessarily about race it was about
ethnicity and othering a group of people
i understand what she was saying but she
didn't say it that way she's stupid for
not saying that she's stupid for
sleeping with dennis rodman well that
was and he's stupid for sleeping with
her
true how does it go to carmen carmen
electra
and whoopi yeah ted danson did it though
i mean there must have been a period
where she was
irresistible i don't know i don't think
she knows she had roofies she has dirt
on them she must charisma she's like hey
oh mr dancing mr rodman you you don't
wanna you don't wanna clean house with
me i guess it'd be a shame if i tell
other people about you
[Laughter]
and discretion
why don't you come back to my house
close your eyes and pretend i'm somebody
else like carmen electra
[Laughter]
or kim jong-un i'm just so happy
all right so there you go no moment
number five klaus schwab
uh wants you to all know and he took
time to say this and this is just to set
it up and i'll get to the specifics with
the other moments but um this should
tell you the spirit of it by the way
also
i think we should have a moratorium on
any uh germans and authority having
global opinions on anything maybe a
little mm-hmm
you guys you know world wars under your
belt all of them
all of them
are bad so klaus schwab instead of
shutting up took the time to remind us
as to who's really in charge
let's
also be clear
the future is not just happening that's
just a scary the future is built by us
by a powerful community as
you here in this group and we've been
expecting mr bond we have some means
to improve the states of the world we
have laser shocks but two conditions are
necessary
necessary the first one
is
that we act all
as stakeholders
of larger communities
said we serve not our only
self-interests but we serve the
community
that's what we call stakeholder
responsibility
and second that we collaborate
and this is the reason why you find
many opportunities here during the
meeting
to engage
into very action and impact-oriented
initiatives to make
progress
related to specific issues on the global
agenda okay a couple of important things
your progress
klaus is not the same as
well progress it's not the same as
progress it's not the same as progress
because you want us to link arms with
you anytime germany starts talking about
collaborating with anyone time to shut
it down okay
time to shut it down always and let's
yeah i'm sure they're really concerned
about the community i don't know if you
know this was a quote i believe it was
ronald reagan nine most terrifying words
in the english language are i'm from the
government and i'm here to help now he
was largely talking about the united
states government imagine that
government involving i don't know japan
china germany turkey
let's just put saudi arabia in there i'm
sure a lot you know our goals are
aligned here this licked his voice i
thought it was my calm sleep app for him
yes
you are getting very sleepy yes you're
tired you're tired you want to die it is
all over
resistance is futile yes i've placed the
cap in the back of your wisdom tooth
give me your passwords
if you break it you will die painlessly
well you'll die
oh well eventually a cyanide is not as
strong as you think it takes a while we
could have easily put in fentanyl to
make it painless but we chose not to no
no we like it to suffer it could be two
hours germany people yeah unless we hurt
germany going to germany by the way
stakeholders hey hold on a second can a
stakeholder a
major stakeholder in pepsi does he have
a vested interest in coca-cola no so the
united states how can we possibly be
global stakeholders in not just turkey
not just the middle east
europe
let me just let's let's also put this in
context by the way there are more slaves
right now when you have this global
economic forum okay the world economic
forum there are more slaves right now
than ever recorded history 40 million
slaves you can go to reference i don't
i'm going by wrote here but references
available at with crowder.com i'll make
sure that i post them up there for you
more slaves right now than ever in
recorded history okay they come from
primarily three places continent of
africa asia middle east
how can we all be stakeholders hold on a
second you want a [ __ ] about the united
states for engaging in slavery which was
horribly wrong we fought a bloody war to
end it
hundreds of years ago but you'll be more
offended if i refer
to the continents that still engage in
more slavery than ever as shitholes that
offends you more than them currently
practicing slavery you know the reason
nobody talks about it because it's
pretty tough to acknowledge there are 40
million slaves across asia across africa
across the middle east across the middle
east and [ __ ] about white privilege
here in the united states so that's why
i have to go up there and talk about we
have to be stakeholders
by the way also the environmental social
governance that's the engl that's the
green credit score we talked about
complete bull crap
complete bull crap yeah absolutely just
another way for government to control
you and by the way if their slogan is
not let freedom ring i don't want to
hear it you you don't have the right for
elites to come in and say well we know
what's best and we're going to enforce
that on the planet no no let freedom
ring free speech that's our mission i'm
behind that if he said that at the end
of that speech i would find it very
false yes
now let me finish this
i'm proud to put on a cowboy proud to be
an american
at least i know i'm free yes yes indeed
well our slogan was
freedom
reign but it was mr gutenberg freedom
horrible dictator so sort of was you
know different a little bit misleading
they're right but snopes and it's mostly
true politifact i don't keep it welcome
to germany been nicer since the 50s yes
[Laughter]
oops are bad don't look for bridge of
spies in any of our video stores you
won't find it nine but like you've never
made six million mistakes
[Music]
i forgot you're six million times
perfect oh
and it's not just that you that the
holocaust happened
it's that you got other people to join
in across the what what what globe yeah
stakeholders axis stakeholders allies
you can't be stakeholders in competing
companies stakeholders in competing
ideas
it's a violent it's a conflict of
interest and by the way remember while
we're talking about conflict of interest
there is no conflict of interest for the
people at the world economic forum their
conflict of interest is with you the
american citizen remember these are the
same people who produced this inspiring
video about how you
should be happy about owning nothing
[Music]
live in the pod yep
the us won't be the world's leading
superpower they show those flags
wow i'll get back to that
[Music]
you won't die waiting for an organ donor
how you gonna make that happen
force people to donate organs
a laser print oh we'll print one right
now thank god you'll eat much less meat
printers never fail notice none of these
things are requests for people who are
listening on audio
an occasional treat not a staple for the
good of the environment and our health
your body rejects the heart why is it
made by a printer
that's what they need the meat for
pc load letter
polluters will have to pay to emit
carbon dioxide less jobs
there will be a global price on carbon
fiber fossil fuels history no it'll help
make many people human beings
history what the hell was that that was
from the world economic forum that's a
video that they put out they thought
that was a good thing the most
horrifying thing i've ever seen yeah i'm
not kidding and they think people like
this is going to go over really well we
feel very good about this powerpoint
everybody should be horrified by this
that was 2016. that was in 2016 the
world economic forum you just saw that
guy speaking out so when they talk about
stakeholders all this has happened yes
yes and by the way huge problem this is
again dave's like guys guys they [ __ ]
wait a minute they [ __ ] about the
united states they've released it today
yeah
that was in 2016. good lord and they've
only gotten worse they want you to live
in pods eat bugs and rent and not be
able to
buy own anything now just to be clear to
say the united states will no longer be
the world's uh world's superpowers oh
good news okay great well by the way
we'll get to in a second you begging
with your hand out from the world
superpower but instead they say that
it'll be a a will they say it'll be a
group of nations it'll be several
nations who have and they show a bunch
of flags one of them is turkey
i mean the place that kills journalists
yeah yeah yeah oh god donald trump evil
dictator let's subject ourselves
globally under the authority of erdogan
now romania came in behind china on
transparency in international uh the
international corruption index they have
slovakia up there up until 2004
they were still forcing uh women to
undergo four stale sterilizations uh
women of a specific ethnicity uh who the
name illusion i'm not up to date on uh
i'm not up to date on slovakia's
eugenics program
jeez
didn't formally apologize for it until
last year so they believe the united
states and by the way the german flag is
there too which is bad enough yeah so
yeah america won't be the world's
greatest superpower by the way we need
another 40 billion for ukrainia
what the one with this one symbol on it
that's like our old flag yeah it's you
know you know we just remember like your
circle one that's right it's a new reich
it's kind of like your confederate it's
a peace symbol with broken wrists like
this exorcist yes
now it doesn't mean anything no
let's take down the rest of the flags
speaking of nazis let's go to moment
number four that you should all see uh
zilensky's speech the ukrainian guy for
those who forgot uh got a standing
ovation and this is again they just
talked about how in a good thing in 2016
the united states won't be the world's
superpower good god uh well in virtual
speech zelinski told the davos crowd
that russia must be brutally punished
and what he means by that is more money
from the world superpower don't expect
for russia using their special weapons
or their chemical biological
and
more so nuclear
do not give the aggressor the impression
that the world would not resist enough
protect
the freedom and regular
peaceful order in the world with the
maximum efforts possible this is what
the sanctions should be the world is not
a regularly peaceful order
and every period potential aggressor who
wants to wind your brutal war against
its neighbor would clearly know
the immediate consequences for their
actions
oh well then good
create the immediate consequences to
their actions ukraine
teach russia the peaceful order of the
oh oh that's right you can't
well you know what maybe sweden can come
and help oh oh that's right they can't
well maybe just the uk oh oh that's so
what do you mean what do you mean
enforce the sanctions
what do you mean swift consequences do
you mean from the world's greatest
superpower you just bitched about in
2016 and praised our downfall hey how
about this foot your own bill
foot your own bill this is what happens
we get to a few years of peace that just
shows you know the natural peaceful
order anyone here actually believe that
the natural order of humanity is peace
that's how privileged we are yeah we've
had a moment of it
it's not been all that peaceful war's
been going on around the world and
everyone tells us that we're an evil
empire just because the united states
has recognized that the world
historically hasn't been peaceful which
by the way kind of a part of our history
same reason for guns here in this
country right which you guys needed for
every single citizen in ukraine hold on
a second there's an argument for the
second amendment we understand
i think we did so something happened we
fought off the world's greatest
superpower you know colonialists who you
hate to become the world's greatest
superpower the next century which has
never happened before or since so it's
kind of ingrained in our history that we
understand the world is a little bit of
a violent place instead you guys in
europe say no no no let's all uh we're
all stakeholders let's hold hands we are
the world oh my god here comes russia
please americans help us
nope russia could take all over you know
what russia could take all of europe and
it wouldn't even affect us that much
if we didn't want it to
we could be entirely independent whether
it be a land war in the united states
either they're gonna have to nuke us or
[ __ ] us economically they're not
trying the former right now they're
trying the latter and they told you
that's what they want they told you in
their own video that they want the
united states to crumble as a superpower
who else do you want to fill that void
sweden
shut up for a guy whose country is
currently getting pummeled he has a lot
of time to make these appearances yes he
does didn't he do like the emmys or the
oscars and uh he did something like the
met gala thing yeah that's all in there
like jeez man he showed up and he
slapped ricky gervais yeah
rough well he talked about donbass and
so you know you don't do that
so by the way henry kissinger who's
still alive wow
that's the biggest news of this segment
commented uh
i haven't heard that name he's 98. is he
really yeah every time i read him like i
thought he died i thought it was 98 in
the 70s yeah
i thought he was like dead for 98 wow
that is insane
so he actually they're asking him stuff
that's a great idea here's the thing
he's actually somewhat right here which
is really smart yeah well he's in this
one he recognizes reality and he
recommended that ukraine give up land to
russia this is what he said uh i'm
assuming i don't know what he sounds
like negotiations need to begin in the
next two months before it creates
upheavals and i don't know why winston
churchill yeah
and tensions that will not be easily
overcome
ideally the dividing line should be
returned to the status quo ante not all
henry kissinger ideas are good most of
them are crap this one is at least
provides some balance to the
understanding i'm just so surprised from
the left that was rock against bush
anti-war you know rage against the war
machine and now they're willing to send
billions of dollars to ukraine for a war
i just
you know i
something smells and it's usually
germany yeah no this is this is actually
a good idea because there's not a lot of
options outside of this right so this is
what they did in the baltics they
basically just carved these places up
that were ethnically already separate
anyway and so if that really is true and
i'm not a big fan of some sometimes you
know a neighbor comes knocking and
you're like well we'll just give you
part of our country like that's not a
great policy because you end up without
a country eventually but that could be a
way to stop this like either that
happens or you guys get overrun this is
how things go unless you call on your
neighbors to help you and by the way
neighbors are in europe europe how about
you help yeah how about you send 40
billion europe how about you impose
sanctions europe and let us stay out of
it no we would we would but for too busy
making free internet for our citizens no
no because you're americans you're just
such warhawks and blah blah blah blah
blah more money please more money please
no no how about habit no how about no
well 40 billion invisible dollars it's
just insane it really is yeah we need
all that at home and we're just sending
it away and why yeah what do you think
they're going to do with because stephen
king wore a shirt
thank god
i prefer him wearing a any shirt i do
agree it could be worse
yes i prefer him in that shirt
but it's meaningless it's a meaningless
gesture
it absolutely is and it's like
look
you know why we should have the world's
greatest military
for us
yep
i believe in the world's greatest
military now i think that there's i
think there's absolutely wasteful
spending in the military so you [ __ ]
about the military-industrial complex
you mean that you don't like the united
states can spend all of this on its
military you'll see these comparisons
all the time during peace right the
mayor you know america can spend this
much on its military but not on the
health care well okay now you see why
sweden can give free [ __ ] to their
citizens because they've gone
decades with not only not paying two
percent not only not paying america's
four percent paying zero percent yeah to
nato
takes a little bit of time to develop
that technology carriers don't exactly
build themselves yeah yeah so we're
really the only country in the world
with a kind of a functioning navy that
we have people don't understand that
yeah
well really that it takes centuries of
experience to understand that kind of
war and have that kind of a capability
every if there's a war at sea the entire
world will rely on the united states so
how about you know what you start
sending us some stuff how about that how
about you start sending us some money
europe sweden
everyone start setting the united states
hey hold on a second sweden or people
say drugs are cheaper in canada well i
wonder why that is genius canada send us
those free drugs well we can it's our
taxpayers uh it's because we do it
through a taxpayer subsidies oh you mean
canada first guess what you didn't
invent the drugs send them on over hey
by the way if you don't like it uh take
down that maple leaf and run the stars
and stripes baby yeah we're an empire
apparently so you're not canada anymore
yeah you're gonna be the 51st state and
by the way we're going to call we're
going to refer to you officially is what
we call the joke state
you're going to be alaska too yes
we're not even going to purchase this
one yes and we're going to appoint a
czar in charge of alaska too
and uh that that uh that that czar is
going to be uh well it's just a hologram
of john candy
send us that blackface guy he's pretty
funny yeah i'll send him yeah yeah that
guy can stay yeah
oh no that's your punishment just keep
yeah yeah you just keep giving yourself
enough rope gosh i grew up with this in
canada all the time i remember i had a
teacher saying we don't have you know
the united states indian soldiers we
have the peacekeepers canadian they
actually call good peacekeepers
so are soldiers yes that's the problem
you know when you even we were talking
about that is freedom comes at a price
that's why you can go and see walls with
people's names on them in dc and the
people that have died for this country
that's why we don't have
a show on monday you know it's it's the
fact that people serve this country and
there is a cost of freedom that's why
people aren't getting mortared and they
have time to run around and go i'm
non-binary let's fight about that right
you think anybody getting shot at has
time to tell you that [ __ ] no of
course not it's because we're so safe
they have been safe you know what they
say there are no lgbtq aip in trenches
[Laughter]
yeah but nobody's going we need a
pregnancy military suit yes when there's
actual problems and things at stake
that's ukraine right now they're going
please send more stretchy maternity
flight suits but you're only free but
you're only saying this stuff because
you're buying into this agenda the key
of ghosts is in her
trimester
i don't know wow i didn't see this
commercial till now it's gonna haunt me
until i'm dead i know which is roughly
around 20 30 according to the yeah yeah
pretty much
they'll speed that process up you will
be several superpowers and you will be
dead and you can rent your groceries yes
it might make sense
also they'll increase the death tax so
your family can't get your own hands you
don't need to drive anywhere vitamin d
for the birds yes
no outside walk you want to eat you you
think that you have the right to eat uh
you know a diet of your choice you're a
real piece of work mr lando
here's your crickets what child would
you like to keep
oh
no but he's absolutely
wrong it is absolutely horrifying
and we need to cut ties to the rest of
this god forsaken world that is europe
i'm sorry it is it is just as bad
as a lot of the countries that people
it's just as bad as the [ __ ] old
countries they just have better lighting
they have better sconces that's all if
if putin wants to redeem himself there's
a place he can invade right now look at
the price of freedom right now ukraine
hey they're paying a price yeah
otherwise they can be subjugated to
russia and this is also why by the way
going back to the idea of native
americans or you had this thing in
canada with the french and the plains of
abraham we gave it back to them
we want reparations you know you have
native americans this and by the way i
think it's the lakotans there were 20
000 when they took the black hills and
then genocide was committed and now
there's a mere 170 000.
um do the math no
you're a conquered people that's what's
happened it's actually sort of like in a
company we've talked about this if some
if you think someone maybe needs to be
fired you should do it right away
because it's the best thing for them and
the united states should have said to
every group of people look you are now
american no we won and by the way the
way that you're going to be subjugated
is uh you're free just don't rely on
everybody else to pay for your stuff
that's it so us instead of enslaving you
is you now live in a country where we
demand freedom of everybody you just
can't come to us and start demanding
free crap from somebody else that's it
as opposed to what germany would have
had done as opposed to what russia would
do as as opposed to what they did as
opposed to what uh uh genghis khan did
as opposed to attila hunt as opposed to
all of humanity
the natural order is not peace
and and peop these people are
are smart enough to know that they're
smart enough to know that so they're
lying because they want to create a
society in an image that what well they
have the haves and you have the
have-nots hey by the way most of these
people are leftist socialists just to be
clear not capitalists let's just be
honest about that let's go to moment
number three because this is an
important one so we've gone through we
will all be stakeholders right we've
gone through uh the last one which was
uh oh that's right i forgot his name
something we don't own isn't that
exciting isn't it exciting yeah
and by the way you also won't own
yeah it's great oh thank god like that's
almost a bad analogy it all makes
perfect sense so here's number three
because don't think about what they want
to make sure is that we don't do what
we're doing here uh this is the world
economic forum
they also want to do away with free
speech so here's australian e-safety
commissioner that's a real job julie
inman grant
said there's a need for
recalibration on freedom of speech we
are finding ourselves in a place um
where we're we have increasing
polarization everywhere and everything
feels binary when it doesn't need to be
so i think we're going to have to think
about a recalibration of a whole range
of human rights that are playing out
online you know from freedom of speech
to the freedom to
you know to be free from online violence
or the right of data protection to the
right to child dignity
a lot of that doesn't mean anything but
the parts that i got were horrible
recalibration on freedom of speech but
by the way again we're all global
stakeholders
hold on a second we're the only country
with freedom of speech you can be
arrested in australia for saying
something offensive you can be arrested
in europe for there's a man who was
arrested for doing a cover of kung fu
fighting at a karaoke bar i guess it's
not really a cover at that point he's
just doing karaoke but the point remains
so let's link arms with
the united states what do we have well
we have the first amendment okay but now
you're all going to be stakeholders in a
global economy where they don't believe
in the first amendment
well that's a conspiracy she just said
it she just said it who gets to decide
free speech and by the way
don't think that it was lost on us [ __ ]
is not even australian
[Music]
that's a knife
that's an australian show her again
she's supposed to be an english person
yeah but the real thing feels binary
when it doesn't need to be not
australian that's not an awesome
recalibration of a whole range of human
rights that are playing out online not
australian now show the australian
[Music]
that's a knife
so i will listen to nothing that you say
if you don't sound the part you are not
you're not worthy to be trusted
how is she australian how long she's not
no do you know what she meant by that
last part that was particularly chilling
she said something about children where
she said right to privacy but then the
dignity of children so dignity of
children though i caught that too
dignity have you ever heard does that
mean yeah yes yes i transitioned i do
believe i looked at my four-year-old
wiping his booger between the velour
couch cushions and said that's a
dignifier
he's always wearing a tux very very
non-formal boy yes of course he poops on
it really yeah love i'd love to know
like you raise a kid to have dignity
dignity something that you learn over
the years and you eventually form class
and respect for other human beings
you're not like your kid is not
dignified no if you turned around for
five minutes and it
your kid's gonna that's why you fall up
on the counter take as much candy as you
want yeah you take a dump in the sink
yeah we need to have dignity of children
what does that mean don't remember don't
forget what online violence she talked
to yeah online violence the words are
violent the words are violence dignified
okay so yeah i understand where you're
going with this what does it mean online
violence words that you don't like
insults that you don't like dignity of
children means what children being able
to transition lgbtq aaip and not be told
what to do by i don't know parents well
she basically wants it to be the lost
boys yeah the closest thing to a
dignified child would be not introducing
children to any form of sex at a young
age that would be the closest thing to
dignity of a child by the way quick
question uh just just to clarify uh she
that that's the same country that built
the uh the camps right there for fun
camps for everybody to go to and uh and
made you pay to take a taxi there yeah
or or
also mandatory gun buyback look yeah
look somewhere that place australia okay
i don't like you
all right i'm not going to listen to you
because i don't like you i don't like
what you have to say not all the people
of australia pogo great there's some
great australians out there steve irwin
fantastic but australia look you don't
get to you don't get to condemn again
the united states this american well why
am i doing that it's american cultures
culture's a it's a gun culture we had a
mandatory buyback yeah you're also a
country that was a penal colony for
rapists and murderers and then you took
guns away from law-abiding citizens
you're devolving
we don't want to have
a a a shared stake in that you can keep
it just let us keep ours
i believe in that i believe in national
borders i like it i like borders
they help yes
if nothing more than to keep canadian
clearly better than barnes and noble
some canadians now
moment number two uh
germany back to germany
so you know this will be good
they again they hate autonomy of any
kind so here's german vice chancellor
robert hobbick uh telling the crowd that
countries should resist
looking after their own interests
and annoying
sorry that's just oh that was the last
time they tried to tell the rest of the
world what to do uh it's
force of habit uh
here's the real clip
first of all i would say that we have to
stick to global markets if we are now
and this is a tendency i feel everywhere
in the world also in my country as well
also in europe if we are now saying okay
first of all
germany and other countries are caring
for themselves then we will
increase the crisis if we are only
caring for our own food supply
or energy supply it must have a
disastrous effect on the prices on the
market so first of all we have to keep
the markets open second we have to see
that we have to solve one
problem not on the back of another one
so if we are now increasing the
production of fossil fuels and coal
power plants all over the place there's
a drought in india you mentioned it we
will definitely
have uh
more problems in the next years to come
so hmm
i'm sorry sir this that answer was the
stupidest one so far and every answer
was stupid ridiculous and you spoke
after kamala harris and joe biden
what's in it for you you are a marvel
what's in it for you
well it's um
global dependence for the chancellor of
germany
by the way groceries delivered by drone
order them on my phone cricket sandwich
for germany yes
i love how germany just announced that
they were re-firing some coal power
plants because of the uh rush exact
issue with energy but by the way you've
talked about this in china
how people pull up the ladder right they
become successful then they pull up the
ladder right that's exactly what these
countries are doing developing countries
need cheap energy you had it germany
started the united states so did
everybody else now that you've gotten to
a certain point you're like no no no no
no cheap energy for anybody else let's
make it very expensive and they try and
sit down india and chastise them for
using russian oil like oh no no no you
must think we care you use more oil from
russia in an afternoon than we get in a
month so you can shut up
well i think that if you're no no no no
no no no you know you are an [ __ ]
i don't care
and i think german i think that india is
not a country that has it right by the
way but you have no right to tell india
what they can and can't do oh nobody
said india had it right no nobody said
india had it right the indians don't
think that they have it no they don't
germany by the way they do we can bring
up overlay g they continue to buy
russian gas yeah and uh also let's be
clear about this where he's talking
about let's not create a problem on the
back of other problems yeah that's all
you've done i literally said we need to
keep the markets open you close you
you're the shutdown people
we need to be open for business what
whole world what except for when i tell
you you have to be close for business we
shouldn't have we shouldn't create
problems off the backs of jews what off
the backs of other problems what i say
so like a recession and then the other
problem is hitler you know what i mean
like the back of it how many people does
it take to fix
a recession right
it takes
five million no five what five or five
four to try and fix the recession and
the fifth to say that's not recession
that's cyclone b
tucson yes
we use the wrestle cyclone for energy
that's right yeah yes till we find out
it's very it's very much not green no no
no no and king's people yes oopsy
so germany by the way talking about
creating problems in the back of other
problems well they shut down their
nuclear reactors let's just be clear
here while they're talking about global
energy oh that always works so this was
part of their push toward green and
renewable energy by the way know how
many carbon emissions come from nuclear
energy how many anywhere uh none oh
and that would be oh so that would fit
in with the idea that there will be
penalties for carbon emissions but they
also don't want nuclear energy which by
the way is not only
the most carbon neutral i guess if you
want to use that term it also has the
fewest amount of deaths per kilowatt
hour when compared to other renewables
so hey hold on a second if it saves one
life what happened with that
but they don't like it why because it's
not really about and let's be clear
about this this is not a conspiracy and
i'll get to this and say i'll get to dan
crenshaw's comments that i disagree with
in a second it's not a conspiracy they
say hey you know what we need to uh uh
penalize people who uh emit carbon
dioxide okay nuclear then they say no
why because it doesn't fit in with their
other part that you can't be a world
superpower it doesn't fit in with their
other part that you can't look out for
your own self-interest well we can't
have peep because nuclear power is
something that could be used by
nations across the globe and guess what
they wouldn't be reliant on anybody else
we could all have our own little power
sources and you can fit all of the
nuclear waste that you would actually
accumulate in your lifetime in a can of
diet coke or you put it under your desk
your entire lifetime no carbon emissions
but
no we don't want to do that why because
they want you to be dependent on the
government and like it so they move to
renewable energy well let's see how that
worked out for germany because you don't
want to create problems off the backs of
other problems
so from reuters the government's
position on nuclear energy remains
unchanged the government remains
convinced that nuclear cannot be
classified as sustainable and uh here's
what happened too they're looking at uh
they're looking at blackouts rolling
brownouts and because their power grid
can't handle when they have a surplus of
energy with this uh you know renewable
um they have to sell it at net negative
pricing they have to lose money you to
use energy so when they don't have
enough people have to basically ration
energy and then they have too much and
they their country has to
lose money yeah well they're looking at
potential massive blackouts right
happening because of this and that's
what they're saying oh my gosh we're
going to have to kind of spool this
stuff back up by the way hold on i want
to go back to what you said that we
cannot classify it as renewable not that
it isn't or not sustainable sorry but
not that it isn't sustainable we can't
classify it like that otherwise people
would say why aren't you using it right
it is sustainable right right and and so
so nuclear is so dangerous that we're
actually going to put it on a submarine
which people will shoot at and try to
destroy and power that but we cannot
possibly have it with all the
advancement in technology anywhere on
land i sat down periscope too yeah well
you know how that goes
i'm a kelsey grammer fan that was before
snakes on a plane what was the movie the
plane money plane there we go oh that's
right oh my gosh kelsey grammer's best
way yeah and what are they going to do
now they're going to fire up the old
coal plants yes oh those clean things oh
good yeah
this all makes sense so stupid we can't
have nuclear didn't you see the simpsons
intro
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we've watched the various documentaries
on hbo in films they made yeah it's all
bad today's show is going to go a little
bit late because this is going to tie
into our own energy policy which by the
way what are you uh what are you looking
tell me there kevin we got some from the
control room before we move to dan chris
oh okay okay we got someone from control
room before we moved to dan crow is this
is you stopping me from being mad yes
sir maybe okay briefly so that you can
get more mad in one moment oh no so this
is the alibaba president j
michael evans boasting about how they
want to monitor your individual carbon
footprint yeah you won't be able to buy
eat or travel anything i thought it was
just
i thought you're just going to shout
open sesame developing
through technology and ability for
consumers to measure their own carbon
footprint
what does that mean that's
where are they traveling how are they
traveling what are they eating what are
they consuming on the platform
so
individual carbon footprint tracker
stay tuned we don't have it operational
yet but this is something that we're
working on yeah you do yeah you've got
to hop on your private jet to go make
sure it's operational dick
so tracking every single thing that i do
or so
no we don't know what you really eat we
know where you go fantastic this is what
i want them to i want the government to
know nothing about me you know what
that's what i want advertisers i want
you to take a wild guess i don't care
like that that is my information you
don't need it the wild guesses they take
are often very wrong yes well i don't
want chairs i looked one time for chairs
and now all i see is spearheads
i've never once purchased anything from
alibaba
no he's a trustworthy guy i don't want
to go to school i don't believe his name
is actually oh well the 40 thieves thing
that's not so much but
sandals in 2007.
i want to go back now
you don't want people to know that you
went there no
crap tower wasn't that good i'm doing
better now
i mean look it wasn't the worst
experience i've ever had i'm not gonna
lie yeah i mean perfectly fine place i
couldn't afford sandals i went to club
med oh
the closed place next door
i didn't know that when i bought the
tickets yeah you're like this is crazy
it's empty here wow but the price is
good well boy these people in here sure
look hungry let's go to fire fest
afterwards
and then i believe there's a fetish
festival going on somewhere near
brussels
yeah just going on a little tour gonna
get sick bring it home
there's coming back looking like tom
hanks in philadelphia like have you been
on vacation yeah you're wearing dog ears
i was hit with a racquetball yes
repeatedly
all right let's go to moment number one
here uh and this is uh dan crenshaw
who's been a friend of the show i agree
with him on some stuff disagree with him
on some other things
and
the one thing that i will say about dan
crenshaw is if you listen to what he's
saying i understand the point
and i wish that he placed more emphasis
on the point that he makes about the
democratic platform unfortunately and
you see this a lot with conservatives
is in an attempt to find common ground
they believe they're sounding sensible
by
conceding the territory of language to
the left and so here is dan crenshaw
you could argue running defense for some
of the world economic forum's
cornerstone policy and i wouldn't say
that but trying to minimize the idea of
what is a very real thing a concerted
effort in the great reset uh where do
you see the the great reset
right now then where's it where is it
going over the next four four to six
years yeah i just don't know much about
it okay and i don't i don't care yeah it
should
you know
i i think we're obsessing over it on the
right a little bit i think when you call
it the great reset it's sort of it's
sort of it sort of indicates that
there's like a secret
here's a point that he makes that is
good cabal under it all right and it's
not so secret it's just the democrat
party so like again i i just want to
take a step back it's not it's not a
conspiracy it's it is a political
platform
but just like just
you know
we we sound a little crazy
when we start talking about like some
sort of like secret
secret cabal um just fight the democrats
it's the same thing
was klaus schwab crazy when he wrote the
book called covid19 is a great reset
what year did that come out huh i don't
know as soon as covet 19 in the title so
i'm assuming recent
i'm guessing recent but now i'm thinking
2016.
after what i've seen gosh this could be
2012 i know you should read his 2012
book monkey fox yeah it's really
something coming to a theater
the first part of it's really just a
stephen king-like orgy right
with 12 year olds because that's how
stephen king likes to do it read it it
actually happened it's incredibly messed
up no here's the thing
i would and i've said this before too
you if you refer to it as the great
reset
it's not a secret say it's happening in
plain view like he was talking about it
is a democratic party platform i've
always tried to because you'll have
people try and say the fringe right and
the fringe left
what's what's the dnc what's the
democratic party platform what are the
policies being proposed at the world
economic forum we don't believe in straw
manning or picking fringe we believe in
picking the mainstream policies and
policies that get a majority of democrat
votes as it goes to our as it goes to
our legislative system you're about to
say something i was about to say look i
don't always agree with him he has lined
up on the wrong side of several issues
lately and what he should have said and
i like you said you understand the point
that he's making but he knows better
than this he knows that that's going to
be taken and see even dan crenshaw says
the right wing is running with this
stupid reset three you should just say
it is absolutely real there's a meeting
going on in davos right now with people
who would love to upend the united
states and make sure that we are not the
superpower and that their ideals rule
the world they put it in a video yes
they put it in a video saying the united
states will not be the world's
superpower and then that uh that close
schwab character wrote the book the
great reset absolutely this is a this is
a professional level of gaslighting oh
crazy right wingers say great reset no
no let me explain to you the platform of
the democratic party and all of these
and i mean this globalist what would you
call the world economic forum when
people are talking about how we are all
stakeholders in the global economy and
some form of global governance no it's
not a conspiracy theory leftist
globalists they want to initiate and
they are doing this right now and this
man wrote the book coven 19 the great
reset about how we can accelerate the
great reset this is their plan crash the
economy so that you can fundamentally
change it crash the economy make us
dependent on foreign energy foreign
goods and services and create a
permanent class of renters beholden to
the government there you go that's your
great reset they said it if you want to
watch every single breakout panel at
ballroom b of the world economic forum
be my guest
you'll have more examples of this than
you can find in a lifetime crash the
economy make the united states dependent
and beholden to other nations create a
permanent class of renters you own
nothing and like it that's the book the
great reset in the title well if that is
the case joe biden is getting a lifetime
achievement award yes he is on davos i
mean they have more merch out than the
band kiss yes
it's not it's out there yes plus i
thought it was a good one i'll take the
book the video with the panel
would you like to buy my books a great
reset yes
oh would you like you know your
conspiracy that's not real that i wrote
about so it is real yes yeah here you go
but covet 19 i wrote about it 27 years
ago oh crap you will be dead soon
they call me they call me doctor death
steps kiss back up dangerous they call
him doctor death
are they dancing i've got my love gun
but it's not about love and it's not a
it's a
want to kill the jews all night and do
it every day you're drunk go home klaus
i am i've been nine years sober i've
never been more clear-headed i
i told you karaoke was a bad idea
i know you're still popping pills maybe
but the prescription so is it good for
me it's medicine
yes
i'm a i'm a naughty turkey right turkey
yes
that was terrible
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's the test that's if
that's that's kiss
in a nutshell well played all right so
that's the great reset okay right it's
destroyer and the fastest way to destroy
our economy so that you can rebuild it
and the problem is they they want to
destroy our economy they want it but
the left can create nothing they can
rebuild nothing right taxation bill it's
just taking money they can build nothing
for enterprise can bake more pies you
have a set pie with socialism and you
just redistribute it you can bake more
pies if you allow people to create new
things
let's just be clear about that so they
have to crash the economy so they can
rebuild it in whatever graven image they
want but they don't actually have a plan
to rebuild anything then they want to of
course make us beholden to other nations
and create a permanent class of renters
i am reiterating this so that you
understand what the great reset is it is
those three points read the book with it
in the title now yesterday i believe it
was yesterday or maybe it was two days
ago uh former vice president joe biden
said this during a press conference with
the japanese prime minister and when it
comes to the gas prices
we're going through an incredible
transition
that is taking place that god willing
when it's over we'll be stronger and the
world will be stronger and less relying
on fossil fuels
when this is over
hmm
sorry i was just writing down all the
[ __ ]
oh are you done already so i love how he
says uh transition rather than
dictatorial policy changes it's we're
going to transition how are we going to
do that executive orders oh ah
did it go to one to five dollars in six
months
hey joe what's gas price is doing right
now how's the transition going
it's not a transition though no that's
just a quick gruesome surgery you know
it'll be a transition you know like
you're six-year-old you just you're just
you know a nice slow transition that
happens immediately and cripples your
finances yeah well immediately as in the
administration recently canceled or
halted three major leases for oil and
gas drilling oh good more jobs you've
got the cook inlet in alaska would have
provided over 1 million acres for
drilling the interior department cited a
lack of industry interest for the
cancellation and then senator uh senator
murkowski of alaska uh just said that
claim was it's completely false it's not
true
well do they have oil and people want to
buy set oil well hold on a second
wait wait you got to think about
the people of the great state of alaska
oh right you have to think about the the
alaskan tundra wasteland you wouldn't
want to destroy that natural beauty it's
valueless well but i'm just curious so
you're telling me oil companies don't
want to drill in alaska one of the most
oil-rich places on the yes oil companies
are not interested in making money
despite what they've told you for years
about evil oil companies being
interested in making money
yeah
fair i don't know how to follow it but
you're not supposed to now the other
leases don't want it
that fungal he was full of crap man yeah
so it was
other two leases what gulf of mexico uh
halted due to i don't know some
conflicting court rulings the other one
was just joe biden just canceling it
okay now here's the thing
even if you're a liberal
even if you're a leftist okay and you
say well that's good you know because we
need to be on renewable energy all right
we've joked about this in the past
and joked but not really just joking how
do you where do you think you're getting
the energy for your electric car we're
not allowed to use nearly enough nuclear
right
you can't do it with wind and solar
we've joked about that and of course
we've joked about how the power grid
wouldn't handle it well now it's very
real the power grid right in virtually
every area of the country is unable to
handle our energy needs right now so
before the transition which they want to
do more aggressively transitioning away
from fossil fuels this is from power
magazine there's a map right there all
references available ladder with credit
says uh an unprecedented array of risks
ranging from capacity shortfalls extreme
weather extended drought supply chain
issues cyber security solar pv tripping
fuel constraints to wildfires could
impale the reliability of nearly every
north american bulk power system
uh every region west of the
mid-continent independent system
operator this
summer now another quote here john
murray the north american electric
reliability corporation god these are
just long terrible names uh he's look
away he's the director of reliability
assessment and performance he made the
point
what we've all learned from recent
history is that extreme doesn't mean
rare talking about weather talking about
these incidents that take place um look
there are other issues of course joe
biden a fan of these right if you look
at the policies we have a decrease in
coal stockpiles of course we have a we
have a reduced labor force wonder how
that happened right we have a potential
for natural gas shortage potential how
did that happen
this isn't just a matter of keeping the
lights on either this is important this
is important for you to note electric
car drivers
affects you
do you understand that
i'm just going to plug in my electric
car you can't well it's coal powered
it's a coal-powered car yes
now let's just be honest yeah you know
why are we playing this game like
like when mickey and minnie would take a
boat somewhere
it's like we're not at war with uh
money yeah take it to germany because
they hated the jews what are we doing
what a stupid world
and by the way this is in the summer so
you're looking at you're looking at some
brownouts is what they're talking about
you're looking at some potential
blackouts you're looking at a lot of
you're looking at a serious strain on
the on the power grid
let me think let's think about this for
a second because if we continue with
these policies it's not going to get
better
what do you think happens in coal uh
cold when the power grid doesn't work
so slight warmth we're talking about you
know gonna be a little bit warm you
can't air condition your house right you
can't uh drive as far you can you can
have to shut off the air conditioning in
your car car use the outside air the max
ac whatever doesn't really know what
that means i don't know if it means it
recycles there someone can explain below
comment below what max ac means i just
know i hit the button and it sounds
louder but when you consider this
in the cold
countless people will die now extreme
weather kills on average over 5 million
people per year this is one thing that
people don't talk about with climate
change 4.6 million a year can be
attributed to cold weather now just in
texas the ice storm that we had to deal
with yeah last year one where alex jones
came in and a helicopter yeah that that
was fun because he was the only guest we
could get
246 people died
and very few of us lost power entirely
when i was in montreal we had the ice
storm i don't remember how many people
died tell them about something that
lasts a week
so if you have a power problem right now
in the summer it's inconvenient it's
uncomfortable these kinds of ice storms
happen
in the midwest michigan minnesota
wisconsin in new york vermont they
happen every single year and if we have
a strained power system as it is you put
everyone on electric cars and you shut
down natural gas and coal guess what
your hey what happened to if it saves
one life because you're kill you're
gonna kill grandma and grandpa
so here's the thing the left and this is
what we're seeing with the world
economic forum and we're seeing it with
joe biden they're so busy virtue
signaling through trying to punish the
wrong kind of people wrong think
they can't possibly fathom actually
creating anything of value it's only
destruction we're gonna get rid of gas
okay or get rid of coal okay no more oil
replace it with what
what hey what do you think happens
what's a major problem for wind turbines
in the cold they freeze
try scraping your solar panels
i just did the windshield of my car it's
a slightly larger suv i haven't got it
shot in hell
you think you're gonna get you think
solar panels and wind turbines are gonna
fix it's not possible for it for more
proof look at germany
we can't do nuclear okay what do we do
we need to go to renewable you need to
remember their solution not long ago was
by a tesla then elon musk said he
supported free speech and the former
vice president refused to meet with him
right so don't buy a tesla all right
well i can't buy a car because it's
really expensive
take public transit how's that powered
by stabbing people on the subway i mean
if you could harness that energy yeah
you mean the texas dart system i don't
think we have to worry about it would be
a bullet train it would yes
we could go anywhere no more gas no more
oil no no nuclear great
what
drive an electric car get rid of a gas
car okay how do i how do i power it
you say what i can't use to power it
what are you creating
what are you creating i know you want to
forgive loans with my tax dollars for
useless degrees i understand that i
understand you want to give away free
health care i understand that i
understand that you want us to eat
crickets and you want to put tariffs and
tax on the media i understand that i
understand that you put all of these
taxes on tariffs and now i'm paying five
dollars a year i understand i understand
all the things that you want it's a wish
list right i get it okay and hopefully
enough good little liberals have been
good boys girls and z's this year got it
but how are you going to solve the
problem you were just sitting there
saying we don't want to create problems
right the german chancellor off of the
backs of other problems
they have outlined what they want to get
rid of
and nothing
even within the ballpark of
realistically replacing it because
today's left this is why i will not call
it progressive
i will not call it the progressive wing
they can only destroy they can create
nothing
and that's exactly what every transcript
from the world economic forum or
proposed policy from the squad reads
like speaking of things i hate we're
going to go play on mug club here hate
symbol or not
oh wow that should be fun to play when
i'm this angry excellent and dave land
tell him again where you're going to be
here this uh to rebuild the town of
gaylord gaylord michigan uh sunday night
you can come out to the show please do
come out and support it's going to help
uh clean up all proceeds go to help
rebuild gaylord michigan and you know
what they really need it because their
town's name is gaylord
youtube piss off
[Music]
you